all right malia yes julia where'd you
grow up where are you from originally um
born in phoenix raised in riverside
california
and uh tell me about your family growing
up you had both mom and dad um
no
it's
hard to say i'm
not a mom but um
different dads
different dads
who raised you mostly
my mom your mom
she's filipino
i'm sorry she's filipino filipino
yeah how would you describe your
childhood
um
i don't know i grew up fast
but i didn't have a child to grow fast
as i mean by that being
[Music]
loved my child's an adults
what kind of stuff was going on
um chaos basically
any abuse
yeah
physically sexually mentally
what age did that start
nine
i'm sorry nine nine
i have um nine sisters four brothers
who is who is sexually abusing you
uncles cousins and
your mom's boyfriends
yeah
i've heard you in
school i'm graduating you graduate high
school
and where'd you go after uh
i went back to arizona
my life just went to hell
for drugs
yeah
yeah i
started 14
i ran away
where'd you go
with him with yeah
arizona
arizona and everywhere
[Music]
how are you supporting yourself
right now or back then over there um
just sex trafficking all that
did you have somebody uh do you have a
pimp back then
i don't
think her guy takes care of me
yeah
is that still kind of what you're into
um no no i'm not
not now i mean
i did present time
i've been saying how long i had a long
time
how do you support yourself today now
i'm through um
[Music]
i'm on welfare i mean yeah welfare
assistance
i'm trying to stay off the street
because
which i basically stay off the radar
you know i'm trying to
do good things
but it's just
i'm trying so hard that i'm just [ __ ]
out basically
yeah what's your drug today
my joker's health
damn
i'm sorry myth your spin has been since
i became my i was a prisoner of a heroin
addict
and i just quit
maybe
seven months ago
yeah they presented heroin and
um
math
i always mixed it
because i had like that roller coaster
yeah
where do you stay down
i have an sro well you do yeah
so you but you lived in the streets as
well
you've lived down the street as well yes
nice
how long you been down here in skid row
um two months two months where were you
before this
and um
[Music]
be nice
[Music]
didn't work the street because i didn't
want to go back i mean
how many times been arrested done how
many times you've been arrested uh
multiple
no most of the time i'm about
drug charges and um position
but i was in arizona and mexico and
um
i learned mexico and um
yeah
you still have contact with your family
no they don't want nothing to do
[Music]
what age did you
become transgender i'm
i'm sorry
14 14
was that
difficult for you
no
no
well i didn't know
to do that man the guy
the [ __ ] my life
yeah
how did you [ __ ] your life
i went
jake i never go into taco bell
[Music]
the taco bell bathroom
i'm sorry can i talk about bathroom
time i had a pleasing man and taco bell
bathroom show me how oh he showed you
how to please a man in taco bell
bathroom
yeah that was the start of your career
do you have friends today no i have no
friends at all none
really
um gotta be a hard life yeah lonely life
yeah pretty much i'm trying to like
i want to settle down and just [ __ ]
find someone but
everybody's just like
okay i get
i'm doing all this prison time and
i get out
doing everything's changed the whole
place where i was at changed
um
this isn't like in arizona that's why i
came back home here i could california
my home but you know
both in phoenix over there and they
dropped me off they let me out and i'm
not back on my own uh stopping ground
where i was
did everything's changed because it's
owned by um as an east side of phoenix
was owned by um asu asu college
so they changed the whole
body onto um
skyscrapers
big departments and you know
everything's changed she's like
yeah
unless i'm trying to figure everything
out on my own
because that's how the how to um
how i can survive alone without
the opinion anybody but
do you feel like you've just been
surviving the rest yeah i've been trying
but i mean it's like i'm trying to catch
up
but i think i'm like trying to kick it
like
somebody slows me down
i'm backed up just
i'm a type person though i mean
i put up with a lot of [ __ ] i put up put
it with
people talking bad about me and they
don't even know me i mean
it's a year from like year to year i
mean it's like
this is
nothing about me
they're calling me this calling me that
and i'm trying to show them not that i'm
not even that
i mean
what was the best time in your life what
are you what's your best memory
for this time
in my life or with a child
anything
i would say the best the best thing in
my life was getting my dog
no
i only had him for like two months now
since i moved there
and that was at what age
there's just recently this is just
recently okay
okay
yeah he's a virgo too
i'm a virgo he's a virgo
he just celebrated his um
birthday sunday with me
so our birthdays are on
september 5th
so we celebrate our birthday together
i mean that's my i mean
that's my bless my best friend right now
he's my um
confidant or my
emotional support animal physically
but i talk to him like he's human
he acts human
but he's i mean we met him and you'll
see he's really really
he's a really good dog
but the thing is not me i keep thinking
i'm wearing them down
because this is that
i heard on the radio i heard a sound and
say
that an animal a dog
a canine would
do your dog owner
he will feel what you feel
you'll feel your emotion
and i want you a lot
all right
what's your biggest regret
this is your um but i can't be me
i'm sorry
the biggest regret is that i can be me
that's like i have to walk on
[Music]
i have to walk on each house around this
place
sorry
being trans is difficult even here in
your life yeah
what kind of stuff happens to you
i gotta be calm and gotta be
so
we're not right i guess i don't know
i guess someone some other chance gave
they gave us bad name because i guess
their scandal is or trifling or whatever
whatever they did
i'm paying the consequence for her
whatever
i don't know
so i feel
i don't know michene
they're just trying to live my life you
know shut to
do the right thing trying to
yeah i remember ever i remember when
getting high used to be fun
no it's just like
just like [ __ ] now it's like
everybody's everybody's judging
everybody everybody is [ __ ]
society's changed
big time
what's been the lowest point in your
life
what's been the lowest point ever the
lowest point in my life is when i lost
my mom
yeah
it's the lowest
what would you say is the most important
thing you've learned in
life in my life was
another thing your
how to accept me
how to love me which i do love me
even with all this [ __ ] around
how'd you love me
do whatever happens
whatever happens to me
i forgive them forgive them
all right
well thank you so much for sharing
yourself yeah
i wish you the best of luck right here
you